[Music]
welcome to there be spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's time to
break out your spiked bat and get ready
for the walking dead with the release of
episode 2 of season 10 the first episode
of the season seems to kickstart the
Whisperer war and throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about episode 2 and its
ending there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you aren't fully caught up yet
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now that's your last chance to back out
but without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into episode 2 of season
10
okay so episode 1 showed a satellite
crash landing in whisper territory
started a forest fire that would make
the Amazon fire look like the Amazon
fire stick yeah these jokes suck though
they managed to put the blaze out alpha
became aware of them trespassing and we
got into a week-long staring contest
that we got to see the build-up to today
episode 2 picks up seven years ago with
alphas backstory continuing where we
left it last time and it pretty much
shows the first time that she and Lydia
met by her whilst the episode structure
itself bounces back and forth between
time periods
this opener really is incredible it's
got one of the goriest deaths I think
I've seen in the show for a long long
time and it brilliantly cements just how
changed out there is now a psychiatric
ward may not be the most romantic
setting for a first day
I'll admit that but alpha and beta the
meeting feels like two star-crossed
lovers caught in the middle of the
zombie apocalypse throughout the episode
is alpha doing her best Sinead O'Connor
whilst we have beta cap fishing with
someone else's face this subtext really
drives the episode and it's actually
kind of intentionally funny watching the
two talking or as I took it playing
simple things like when alpha is asked
about her name and she just says the
dead don't have names made me smile a
bit but it lets you know that she's
pretty messed up
beta says he doesn't really want this to
end and by this I mean the sound of
growling zombies and it's very much
Beauty and the Beast but
of the beast' the episode perfectly
paints out just how much of a leader
alpha is and how she's outstanding at
getting people round to her way of
thinking she kills betas last human
attachment in order to prop herself up
as the new one and it's clear that this
entire time she's been playing
three-dimensional chess beta has clearly
lived in isolation for a long time and
to me at least this paints out the fact
that the whisperers are all probably
lost souls that alpha has taken in when
they are at the most vulnerable and
manipulated them in order to fall in
line to her way of thinking we see this
exemplified in the present when we catch
up with a camp and see one person who
refuses to fall in line this woman is
the sister of the character played by
Thora Birch whose baby alpha gave up a
tell top and it's clear she feels like
one of the Martha's from The Handmaid's
Tale
however alpha is able to use fear to
really put the woman on edge and just as
we think we're about to see her kill the
girl she instead strokes her air and
wins our background this use of her
motherly instincts is clearly what's
keeping everyone on her side and as far
as cult leaders go alpha is one of the
best but that doesn't mean that the
woman's completely back to ground level
and later in the episode she set off
again and Dora kills her in order to
stop her from attacking alpha it's a bit
of a twist but again as I said it's
immense that alpha really has this code
controlled on the level of a Manson or
Jim Jones and she's near untouchable
Dora is promoted to a gamma and we hear
the chant we're strongest when we kill
our own blood which could highlight what
plans alpha has validity on the line
later discovers alpha pondering over
this pointing out that Lydia isn't dead
and mirroring his rage about the death
of his last human attachment alpha 2
goes off on one this happens at the same
point as mentioned earlier in the recap
which is when betas friend is killed by
alpha and you really get the feeling
that the two are yin and yang living in
a circle and support system that is
manipulative on both sides together they
chant their mantra we walk in darkness
we are free we bathe in blood we are
free we are nothing we are free we fear
nothing we are free we need no words we
are free we embrace our death we are
free this is the
of the world now is the end of the world
we are the end of the world it's at this
point that we see alpha step out into
the ravine from last time where she
comes face to face with Carol and yeah
it's a really oh yeah its own moment now
in the episode three preview it looks
like alpha once again uses manipulation
to draw the survivors out calling them
to a meeting place to talk before
attempting to murder them all this
ambush I think will be another big loss
for the group and I can actually see
there being a big death here with alpha
pretty much wiping them out after this I
believe that they will be forced to look
for help from others and luckily for
them you may remember that Eugene
collected satellite parts last episode
which could allow him to extend the
radio signal and thus they can reach out
to the mysterious voice from the end of
season 9 this will allow the survivors
to build up their defenses and they can
finally have a fighting chance against
the whisperers overall I really enjoyed
this episode and so far the season is
two for two in my opinion with this
backstory painting out just how
dangerous out four really is just in
case you didn't know it's on and I can't
wait to see what happens in the next
episode
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on episode 2 and what you hope to see in
the future drop them in the comment
section below and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my full breakdown of the
first episode if you need a quick
catch-up you want to come chat to me on
Twitter then make sure you follow me at
definition YT and if you want to join my
discord that make sure you click the
link in the description below we've got
an awesome community that's made up of
people just like you and it's the best
way to stay up to date with the channel
so hopefully I see you over there after
this also just want to let you know that
we're currently giving away a free copy
of spider-man far from home on blu-ray
and all you have to do to be in with the
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on The
Walking Dead in the comments section
below the competition closes tomorrow so
it's your last chance to take part and
best of luck to everyone who's involved
this is the channel for people who are
never missing tell
vision so if that's the kind of thing
you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]